in the summer between my
first and second year of graduate school
at southern illinois university
carbondale
i moved into a trailer park and
specifically into a trailer at the very
edge of the trailer park and there i
wound up
adopting some kittens and so this is the
story of that and i
do have to tell you a little bit about
the trailer park which i'll i'll go
into here and i'll tell you a lot more
about that in some other
some other video so you know trailer
parks
there's a lot of different kinds of
people who live in them and
if you live in a university town
especially you know the further south
you go
you might find quite a few of them and
they you know they vary considerably
some of them are pretty sketchy places
some of them are a bit more
upscale and expensive and have various
amenities
and the deeper that you go into a
trailer park typically the
the older trailers at least this is the
case back when
i was living in and spending time in
trailer parks they would be
way towards the back and my trailer was
the
second trailer from the very end
of the park as a matter of fact there
was
um something almost like a it was sort
of like a dump they would
throw you know some garbage there and
cover it up with with landfill
there was construction stuff that they
would dump there and then beyond it was
the railroad tracks
at one end of my trailer was a woods
that separated off our trailer park from
another trailer park and then
you know across the dirt road from where
we were there wasn't even gravel
at that place uh or that point in the
trailer park there was another
woods and so you know it was kind of
in the countryside it was a little bit
out of
town but not entirely out of carbondale
itself
and the trailer that i rented i you know
chose the cheapest one i could get they
charged me 175
rent per month and you got what you paid
for you know the
trailer was older than me the walls were
about this thick
poorly insulated the windows um
you know you could open them up and then
you had to prop them open
and there was you know an air
conditioner as there is in all of these
things but i i never turned it on
because i knew that the trailer was just
leaking
um you know cool air so there wasn't any
point in it
and you know for a young guy
especially somebody in graduate school
who was spending
most of his time either studying or
working out or cooking or things like
that it was it was great it was perfect
for me you know i
had a stipend for my fellowship and you
know that 175 dollars plus utilities
didn't really cut into it that much
so i had plenty of money for you know
food and beer and you know things
buying books and things like that and
there were as you know another feature
of trailer parks is that there's
quite often a lot of stray animals and
when you live in a place that has
students this is kind of a sad thing
students add even more to that because
you know undergraduates will adopt a
kitten
or a puppy and then they'll move back
home and they'll leave the animal behind
them which is how i got another one of
my cats later on black monkey
but there was a stray and this stray
mother cat she had a litter of kittens
the first
the first year that i was there and
there were five of them and these
kittens would actually they almost
nursed her to death
unfortunately they would knock her down
and nurse on her and she'd try to you
know
wean them and get away and eventually
she just took
off but she was being fed by the people
who lived
just you know the iowa was the second
trailer
at the end of the park then the people
who were at the very very end
they would they would feed her they were
a couple and you know i saw these
uh five kittens dwindle you know one of
them got hit by a dump truck and
most of them were pretty feral there was
one of them that i could approach
a little white cat but eventually she
disappeared as well
so i thought oh that's that's it for
them then
those neighbors the next the next year
in in the spring those neighbors moved
and that stray cat that you know
mom cat started coming around she was
big she was
you know she may have had some maine
[ __ ] in her or something like that
and i started you know i didn't have cat
food as such but i would find stuff that
i could give her
and you know she'd come up to me and she
was quite affectionate and you could
tell like she was super super pregnant
again
and then she disappeared and i didn't
see her for a long time
and i was it was like maybe
march april probably march because it
was so warm down there
and i had my trailer door wide open
um you know because again i i didn't use
air conditioning or anything like that
it was open the windows and i put fans
at
either end of the trailer and when it
was a nice sunny day i'd
uh you know leave the door open and so i
i'm just sitting there
in my trailer with the door open and i
hear this little
you know this tiny little little kitten
sound
and i look and she's coming up my steps
with a kitten in her mouth
i'm sitting over on the couch in my my
living room and she goes into my kitchen
looks around and then puts the kitten
underneath my refrigerator my
refrigerator had kind of a gap it was an
old-fashioned kind
and i was like well that's weird so
you know i get up and i look and sure
enough there's a kitten like staring
back at me from under the refrigerator
and the mom cat takes off and then she
comes back
and she comes up the steps again with
another kitten shoves that kitten
underneath the refrigerator
that kitten goes in there and i was like
wow she's uh
i wonder what she's doing you know and
so i go and sit back on the couch and i
figure out
leave her alone and see what happens and
she brings in two more kittens and puts
all of them under the refrigerator
and then she just leaves you know she uh
i think she she didn't want to have too
much to do with kittens after her
first bad experience and so i go and i
look under the refrigerator i'm like and
there's all these little eyes looking
out at me
and you know some of them were hissing
at me as well they didn't know what to
make of me
so i go and i you know put my arm under
the refrigerator
and i pull a kitten out and i had like a
recycling bin
so i take the recycling bin and put some
you know some uh
clothes in it and blankets and i put the
first kitten in there and it's looking
up at me
and you know not really sure what's
going on but it was clearly like you
know
uh weeks old and so
um you know i reach another one out and
another one out and then i can't get the
other one
because it started to crawl up inside so
i'm like oh crap it better not like get
to the mechanism
you know i don't know exactly what's in
the back of this fridge but it can't be
good for it
and so i had to pull the fridge out and
kind of tilt it i took some of the food
out that would be like to be spilling
and there i could see it i reach up and
i pull it down and it's hissing at me
that turned out to be the runt of the
litter actually
so now i've got four kittens all in this
um recycling bin
and i thought well i mean this is a kind
of temporary
solution because they're gonna you know
go to the bathroom and
in these clothes and stuff like that i
better start thinking about how to take
care
of some kittens and what what am i going
to do with them should i like
take them to somebody else or what what
should i do so
long story short you know i uh the mom
cat came back
and you know she would like lay down and
i'd let the kittens out of their little
box
they'd go over and nurse on her and then
wander around the
the uh trailer and then the mom cat
would take off you know she
she wasn't interested in sticking around
and she
um you know she she'd go out in the
woods or do whatever she was gonna do
you know i'd give her some
some food and then she didn't want to be
with the kittens all that much she was
like they're your your problem
and then interestingly the people who
were who had you know
left who had lived next door they came
back
and they knocked on my door and they're
like so you know we
we i guess i must have told some people
and you know they're like well you know
there's those kittens and the mom cat
we'd like to take them all
and i said well you can have the mom cat
but i'm
i'm keeping the kittens you know i've
been taking care of them and
i'm getting kind of attached to them i
actually called them the four musketeers
so you know one of them was aramis one
of them was
porthos one of them was athos
and one of them was dartanian and i
forget which ones i named
which other than the runt was named
othos because
she was mean you know there was
something like clearly a little bit
wrong with her she wasn't misshapen or
anything but she had a
terrible temper just like athos right
and i think the two that i ended up
keeping were
porthos who there were two girls and two
boys
and so porthouse and d'artagnan and
actually let me describe them a little
bit
so they were big big little kittens
and as it turns out we figured out that
you know the mom
cat was was pretty giant there was also
this this tomcat around
that we called uh big boo and
he was kind of brain damaged he lived
with an alcoholic in a trailer and i
guess the guy used to beat him
and probably gave him some brain damage
but he also would get in fights with
like all the other cats
and with other animals he had scars all
over them
and boo was pretty friendly but he'd
kind of lose his mind every so
often so he'd like come up to your
trailer and you know you start petting
him and talking to him and he'd be
purring and all that and then suddenly
he'd turn around try to bite you you
know
and he his head was like this big and he
was just a giant cat
so you know the the two girls
were i guess they call like like
tortoise shell or something where it's
it's black and white and brown all kind
of mixed together
and then the two boys were both um
just you know black and white with you
know like
patterns and stuff like that some of
them had they almost looked like they
had goatees or mustaches which is
i think where i came up with the
musketeer thing
and you know word got around that that i
had uh
kittens and this friend of mine chris
who
was studying philosophy used to call him
the illustrated man all sorts of stories
about him
he was a tattoo artist as well as a
philosopher from california and licensed
piercer
which meant that in carbondale he could
like
set whatever price he wanted work
wherever he wanted he was like covered
from head to toe
in tattoos and he took
one of the boys and i think he called
him dion
perhaps and you know i'd see him when
i'd go over to chris's place and
you know he'd play and he was an inside
outside cat you know they let him
kind of roam a bit and i was going out
with this uh this uh
woman at the time and it was one of
those relationships where we could tell
there wasn't an
awful lot of uh future there so when she
moved back to st
louis for uh the summer with her sister
you know we were like well this is this
is it and i and she was like well i'd
like to take the
runt you know i want to take this this
kitten and so i was like okay that's
cool
you know uh and then there were two and
for
for a while i was calling them you know
by their
their three their four musketeer names
but
you know after a while you just kind of
drop that and i started calling them
little boy and little girl and that
became their
main names as well as all sorts of
other names that they got called you
know
a little girl got called little bit a
little bit of kit lit
uh bitlit a little boy got called you
know fuzzy bear
fuzzy cow because of the black and white
stuff
and and he grew very very quickly
quicker than she did although she became
a pretty big
cat as well little boy's head
was like his father's it was like this
big around
he you know when when he was in his
prime you could like give him a
you know like a chicken bone and he
could like a leg bone and he could crack
it with his with his teeth in his jaws
and you know his his uh his fangs were
were big
everything about the the guy was big and
he developed quicker
than his his sister at his
top weight he was 25 pounds now he was
also
fat right so but the vet would take a
look at him and say well that cat should
be 20 pounds
you know so he was he was gigantic uh
as far as cats go well maybe not for
some people but you know
most people look at him and go wow
that's a big cat
and little girl was you know not as big
as little boy but she was also
pretty big and both of them were very
agile
little girl would like jump up from the
floor to my shoulder
i used to call her little parrot that's
right because she would sit on my
shoulder
and just like look around you know
and you know i i lived with them in that
trailer
for years and years in graduate school
and then you know they got they they got
to go outside but i would put them on
little cat leashes i would uh you know
they had collars and i would tie
some clothesline and then they could
wander around the yard
every once in a while little boy would
figure out how to throw his collar and
then i'd have to go looking for him
sometimes he'd be in the woods sometimes
he'd be messing around you know a couple
trailers up sometimes he'd be
over in the dump area and little girl
liked to climb
trees and then i would have to actually
climb there were two trees
in my yard i would have to climb the
tree
and because she couldn't figure out how
to get back down and she'd have the
leash on her so i'd climb the tree
take the leash off of her and then she
would get on my shoulder and like sink
her claws
into me and then i'd climb back down
you know and um you know we we'd like
hang out
and uh um
just i'd read a book and they'd you know
purr and curl up with me or they'd play
with each other
sometimes they'd play with me i do have
a couple other kind of cool stories
about them
one day i came home and this is when
they were still pretty little kittens
like about this big
and i i get i get in i think i came back
from the grocery store
which was you know about half a mile
down the road
and i can't find them anywhere and i'm
calling for them where are you little
boy little girl you know
and i started to get really worried i go
out in the yard i'm looking for them
no sign of them anywhere and then
suddenly i hear like a little
like a yawn they were in the silverware
drawer
where there were these um
cloth napkins and you know everything in
a trailer is kind of rickety
apparently there's there was like a hole
between the closet that the garbage was
in
which they could open up and the sets of
drawers
and somehow they figured out both of
them that that was a cool place to be
when i opened that drawer there they
were both of them like nested together
in in that spot that trailer as i
mentioned was uh
you know poorly insulated so in the
summer i would set up fans at either end
of it
but it could get to you know 100 degrees
in that trailer and in the winter
um you know again poorly insulated i
would actually
set the thermostat to either 60 degrees
or 55 degrees fahrenheit so in the
winter
we all you know curled up and cuddled up
together and in the summer the cats
would actually like you know
go in the bathroom which was the coolest
room because it had like tile
and they they would pant like dogs and i
i thought that was
really quite strange you know i made
sure to keep the water
well well stocked and all of that
and they were you know really really
great cats
they uh ended up you know following well
being taken along to indiana when i
uh purchased one of the houses on my
family's land with my inheritance from
my
my mother's estate after she died
and then they became completely inside
outside cats and would
range all over the place along with the
other cats that that we had at the time
and they lived to be quite old
unfortunately
my my ex did something pretty terrible
which is when when you know i was living
in north carolina
she asked me well what are you gonna do
with these cats and i said well i think
you're gonna have to keep them because
you know the
kids like them and all that and she took
both of them to
a shelter at 13 14 years old and just
abandoned them there but we had some
some you know we had over a decade of
really great time
together me and those those two kittens
little boy and little girl
um i used to call him also you know the
fuzzy bumble and and uh she had all
sorts of other names as well
and uh they were you know some some
really
great cats kind of a fixture in my life
for
a long time now if they were alive i
think they'd probably
be around you know 25 or so which
really be pushing it for a cat um
but yeah they they were really quite
something so that's that's
that story i'll tell some more cat
stories some other time
you